are you a recovering addict no i'm
actually not
so you're ignoring me that's just
enthused with the lifestyle of
yeah i just find this fascinating right
here's what it is
i am fascinated by the human tendency
to self-destruct that can take many
different forms
uh down here you get the drug addiction
the gang violence the prostitution
but it could also be gambling eating
shopping [ __ ] so many different
all right latonya hello where where are
you from originally
i'm from st louis missouri i love my
hometown
i must say california and all these
other places are truly a joke for me
they're joked how was your childhood you
grew up with both your parents uh
no unfortunately um my dad was
uh killed while my mom was six months
pregnant with me
and i'm the fourth child
from five out of five so uh
i love to tell this part of our story
where
all of my brothers and sisters have the
same dad except for me
and then it goes back to the same father
which lets me know mom stepped out
a relationship so hey um
getting back to my dad's death he was
killed by my aunt's
husband who she is still today married
with
he was uh he jumped in front of an ice
pick and uh
this was in chicago and the hospital was
really really far away so he bled to
death he bled
in so like uh
most men in my life he should have still
been here
[Laughter]
um however
uh the you know my grandfather he
he had a wheat and a cotton field there
were 16 of my mother's
uh uh siblings all again and 16 of them
we had land in st louis uh
which was a wheat and cotton field and
um
that was all taken by you know when the
government started taking people's land
however there is still the three-story
bedroom
i mean house uh that still stands which
has
family secrets inside and um
my mom and uh i'm gonna say about six of
her sisters
were uh molested by their uncles
and um i believe some of their brothers
so um that's when my oldest aunt made a
way for my mom to come out here
and um she only had one daughter and
four boys and she heard
my oldest thing was there's no way i'm
gonna allow my daughter to be
you know dead how we were dead
and uh it's okay for me to curse no of
course
because i'm trying to watch my language
no you you can say anything you like
yeah so
um i remember i remember um
my mom telling me that uh she told her
like man
you got four [ __ ] girls and there's
no way i know you want them to
experience what we
experience so i'll go first and then
i'll make a way for you and then i'll
send back for the rest of them
so by undid that she came down here or
whatever
and she slowly signed back for him so
let me speed it up a little bit
so now i'm 10 years old and i'm out here
in california
and we start off on 59th and mckee
avenue
i love that because that's where my
cousins
started 5 9 east coast credit which is
big man rest in peace
and my cousin clifton who is doing life
in san quentin
so now let's get to me i found myself
kind of [ __ ] up at 10 years old for
the simple fact
i remember seeing things i remember
seeing things that i knew
was not right i remember feeling
things that i knew was not right and
that was wrong but it used to freak me
out because it felt good that it was
wrong
so i guess i was a twisted little kid
already at 10.
so i was fascinated with women with
boobs
coming up 10 years old this is where my
life this is where i remember
my life at 10 years old i remember
liking women um with boobs women that
were natural
women that had ass you know a man just
really really wasn't my thing
anything that i got from a man it was
more so how to sit
how to do this how to talk how to smack
a [ __ ]
you know things like that so uh
that was really the way i looked up to
men
and uh until i realized they had
something that i didn't have which was a
dick
and that there was no way that a woman
was truly going to want me
because i didn't have the one thing that
men didn't have
so we're going to speed it up so then
that made me very very angry because
there was some
chick i was really digging in grammar
school
i mean she was flawless her name was
sabrina moreno
she had little black freckles and long
black
jack curly hair and she had a smile that
was out of this world
and whenever i was here it would take me
back to the [ __ ] movies like
when somebody's walking in slow motion
and their [ __ ] hand is blowing and
their
dress is raising up and [ __ ] and my
heart will literally really really
really beat so that is a true factor
that's not fake so um
anyway i would tell myself i'm gonna
marry this woman
in fact i started getting in trouble
with creative writing
and [ __ ] because you're supposed to
write what you want to do when you grow
up
or who you want to marry what celebrity
crushes
there and mine was all women so of
course the teacher reads that [ __ ]
she finds it disturbing her name was
miss board neighbor
i've developed a crush on her she was a
[ __ ] real
kick-ass nice sexy legs wearing them
spike high heels
wear them fishnet stockings and she was
a little i call them bite size anything
you could pick up
and put on a counter or a shelf i call
that bite size
and she had a short haircut and she had
a little fine mustache
and she would always wear that red
lipstick that would just
make you say [ __ ] that mustache this
[ __ ] is bad
so um i of course even in that in that
grade we had creative writing
and uh her thing was who's your biggest
crush and i wrote her
and what i wanted to do to her so
immediately i was taken out of class
and uh i was suspended for uh
i'm dressing the teacher with my eyes
that made me feel some type of way
because any time i got suspended
i got my [ __ ] ass beat so
i i guess uh that's what you call
resentments i'm still holding on to that
[ __ ]
i believe that's something else that
keeps me getting loaded
i'll have to take a deep breath on this
one
because uh even today i still have
issues dealing with it
so uh let's go to when i was about 13
where the molestation started
where i realized my mom was codependent
and she just had to have a man
to validate her beautiful woman strong
woman
but uh again leaving that codependent
issue
and i just realized that it was truly a
problem
when i completed uh life skills
codependency is some real [ __ ] and it's
a real
issue that some people just don't
realize they have
so anyway let's get to where um
there was a again there was four girls
and one boy in my family and uh
mind you we came all the way from st
louis to keep this [ __ ] from happening
yet we get out here in california
and my mom runs through these men like
like like
like you run through a bag of skittles
not too fast not too slow
but um
[Music]
uh i remember the first man
and uh his name was robert maxie rest in
peace
and now she would get some real nice
this [ __ ] had green eyes he was
yellow bone i had good hair
you know um but again i just liked it
i just wanted you know the manliness
about him you know so
i looked at him as like you know like a
father figure because here it is
like i told you at 10 years old i was
[ __ ] up you know
already with phyllis away about women so
um
you know i like the fact that you have
the green eyes and the curly hair so i
told like my mom like
i'll i'll cut all this [ __ ] off i don't
want this one more i want a little
ass curl like robert right you know
and uh she was like no no you can't do
that
so anyhow robert turned out to be a real
[ __ ]
his thing was he wanted to [ __ ] all of
us you know he wanted to
keep it in the family as they say and um
i remember that [ __ ] getting my mom
pissy drunk and
putting her down to sleep and um
we my mom always kept the house so we
had a house where
there was one bedroom in the beginning
and that was my mom's bedroom
and then i remember him late night
creeping my my older sister has
really huge breasts you know um
they're really really huge right so she
couldn't sleep with a shirt on
or a gal but those [ __ ] at 15
were like out to here dude you know and
now they're out to here now that she's a
grown woman
mine are trying to slowly catch up but
um i remember him
seeing him going opening up the door
pulling the sheet off of her and she
just raises up and there's her breasts
and she's fighting trying to get the
cover and then i would go and step
in and you know i would be like hey
you're not supposed to be in here and he
would
so he would turn around and say you know
your next your little [ __ ]
you know your mother will never believe
you and that's where codependency comes
in at
she's blind she was blinded so uh anyway
um
i remember the next day i was telling my
mom little me
going telling my mom saying you know you
got to keep robert out of bridget's room
you know
that's going to mess with her mentally
and i remember my mom's telling me
looking at me saying
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
know you talk too [ __ ] much
you know and now that i know what i know
about codependency it's like
damn mom did you like sell bridget to
robert
i mean what the [ __ ] was this about to
wear
i'm coming to you telling you and
it's like i talk too much what am i
talking about
but um anyhow you would never know my
mom was in an addiction
and uh don't get me wrong
i love my mom to death um
the only thing i would change about my
mom is that codependency but she's
resting in peace
she died 25 years clean so hey
she's still my protege she's still my
number one she's still my best friend
but she had some [ __ ] issues that
that um
that really really really just uh
[ __ ] all of her daughters up um
well my mom from the day my mom said
that
i would i just figured like this for
[ __ ] gonna touch me i'm gonna get paid
so the game the chase was off so um
uh next boyfriend she had
my sister was uh doing her own thing so
now it was all about me
i was the only adult figure in the house
so uh
he would uh come in
and uh we had bunk beds he would come in
i was at the lower back
and he would come in and he would wake
me up and he would put his hand over my
mouth
talking about a different one now put
his hand on my mouth and he would be
like
hey i've got ten dollars for you for
school tomorrow you know your mom only
gives you guys
three you're a growing up girl can you
still hear me
and you're a growing up girl so uh i
thought you think 10 bucks is like
and i looked up at them and i said
[ __ ] make it 20. and that's when
it was all so
every boyfriend she had i began to look
for his
[ __ ] up ways so that i could
take him down right there was never no
sex involved there was one
that uh this [ __ ]
straight true crackhead he is the
[ __ ] that let me know that
he'll sell his mama okay because
i wouldn't even we weren't even his kids
but i remember him telling all his
friends like
yeah these are my daughters these are my
beautiful girls
but all along he was hitting you know
yeah i got these products
right we were [ __ ] products
merchandise
so um i started getting addicted to
money
so then um i would tell them like
um
you got any friends you got any friends
i could
my breast was the hottest thing going on
when i was young
right because [ __ ] weren't trying to
really look unless they was crazy wasn't
trying to lay down with you
but they didn't mind following then
that's where i got my sugar daddies
and all that so i mean hustling became
at 14 hustling i had sugar daddies i had
little
little uh uh a married little piscer man
uh yeah my breasts my breasts was the
hottest thing going and
to feel the [ __ ] was 30 to suck
on them was 50.
i mean hey my breath again i wish they
would've had youtube back there because
i showed what i had my own little
website so then we want to speed it up
to when i'm about 14
15 she gets with this mexican that i
have
already i had already let grope me and
everything for 60 bucks on the side of
the building he was living in a trailer
and i had already let him grope me so
i'm gonna say that's where my addictive
personality came
when i was about 13 or 14.
so um she decides
he's gonna be her but she's gonna marry
him right and help him get papers
so this is where my nightmare begins so
now i'd have groped you on a side but
you ain't got the decency
now that you're with my mom to let it go
so now you want to start blackmailing me
oh you know and my mom was just like
zero tolerance
of us doing any type of [ __ ] dating
doing anything
so um
the bachelor rate me uh i let my
my mom was working my brother joined the
gang
so it left me and my baby sister and
once i got home i was to start prepping
[ __ ] for dinner
and uh make it make that sorry
[ __ ] at lunch or whatever
and uh you know do do what my mom my
mom's duties was
and uh i remember went going to take a
shower
or a bath and i had a roll ball and i
remember um
right when i was getting ready to take
the robe off [ __ ] came in and
pinned me down and
with his little wrinkled [ __ ] up dick
that even though it didn't last a minute
here it is today i got a 24 year old el
salvadorian daughter she's beautiful
looks just like me still trying to get
connected with her but um
yeah that's nightmare there so anyway i
winded up having a daughter behind
my firstborn and uh
that's where i became very very angry i
couldn't stand me
and um
i didn't want the [ __ ] to happen to my
baby sister so um
i told the neighbors and uh
when it was time for me to deliver the
baby the doctor saw that there was
wounds down there
and that he just pressured me and
pressured me
and asked me was it was it a was it a
consensual
pregnancy like did i want this it's
amazing what
and this was right before technology was
coming up it's amazing how
a scar could say what type of scar
what type of way it's it's uh began
to tell a lot so anyway this doctor knew
that i had been um
forcibly forcefully uh taken and uh
that's how the pregnancy came about and
um
i finally went to my mom and i was like
um
i told her like uh okay like because she
he she kept saying that i was pregnant
that she kept accusing me of [ __ ]
around with
in the streets and my mind wasn't even
there you know
and that's where i've developed this
model of if you're gonna keep on
accusing me then i'm gonna give you
what you're accusing me of doing anyway
so um
i i just became real promiscuous you
know uh
i just uh but it had to be about money
so i guess
um
i don't know i guess i became somewhat
addicted to that lifestyle
so then i'm going to speed it up to um
i got addicted to money and then all of
my home girls they were selling
dope so here it is i got
my daughter and uh
i'm trying to make it and i wanted what
my what
i wanted what what what my um i wanted
what
what my home girls had which was selling
dope so i got into the dope game i
started my own spot over
on stanford and imperial and i used to
score for the nicosia gardens and uh
i almost got killed almost lost my life
trying to open up my own dope spot
in somebody else's neighborhood and [ __ ]
but i went hard in the pain and that's
when i learned
anything that i do i got to do it
wholeheartedly
or not at all if i'm not with it and if
i don't like it or if i've got no
no cost to doing it then i don't [ __ ]
with it
you know i'm not saying i'm a saint but
i'm also a little daredevil and i love
to challenge a man because
i'm already angry with the [ __ ]
because i don't got a dick
that's the one thing that a [ __ ] got on
me that i ain't god and i tell you i
i just i despise me because they got a
penis and i don't
but i could pull up i could pull abroad
i mean i could talk abroad about her
panties
so um here it is i almost got killed
selling dope over in somebody else's
neighborhood
and [ __ ] and then so i had the little
gangster take over where okay [ __ ] you
want to sell dope in our hood
we got shifts up in here so i had a
little bit of everybody up there selling
dope
and uh i remember it being shootouts
um all type of [ __ ] so anyway i just
winded up abandoning
the place i just left it i left the
place just to get with my
baby daddy which is evil d from bounty
hunters
and i got with him and uh
he was a primo head and uh then i
started
uh he started taking my money and [ __ ]
and uh
then i started selling dope on the side
without him knowing out of a little spot
out of a little room 108 and grape
and uh i was selling dope out of the out
of that little room
and uh then they ran us uh the t-zones
and the hunter and the
and the gracies ran up in there to rob
him
thinking that he was selling the dope
but i was the one
telling the dope so um
once he found out i was selling dope
uh it started getting real hectic it
started getting real hectic started
beating the [ __ ] out of me
um it just got real crazy
and um man
so then i he put me on the track so now
i'm out here prostituting i'm out here
for real for real with almost like a
real live pill
[Music]
um i'm out here on fig in 87
like if i got a [ __ ] shift and
um
one thing i just couldn't do i couldn't
but i couldn't i refuse to put on the
on the [ __ ] high heels and the little
[ __ ] dress and all that [ __ ] i refuse
to do that
so young girls were selling
so i went with the with the look of a of
a of a teenager
and boy did it sell i had some
[ __ ]
i had a regular that um
he would get a motel and he would want
to do the scenery type [ __ ]
that uh i was his daughter and he was my
daddy
and uh he was coming down he would be
coming down the stairs
and i'm in this [ __ ] motel i
had a refrigerator this [ __ ] was
stopped by milk and cookies
put all that [ __ ] in the refrigerator
set it up
and then he would buy me this little dot
dot thing so that i when i bend over
i would bend over just right
to where as he's coming down the stairs
and then i'm supposed to i had a script
that i was supposed to like say like
um oh yeah daddy um i'm sorry um
and he would be like oh it's okay your
daddy's a little girl
and he would i was really small man so
he would pick me up
set me on the counter and
he would stand in front of me and he
would say
i would say oh daddy i ate up all the
cookies and
he would be like it's okay daddy wants
something else to eat
and he would begin to go down on me
and i tell you i would have to be
[ __ ] loaded out of my mind
to go through with that because i have
daughters
you know i mean i've done some
demoralizing [ __ ]
um out here to where
i couldn't even sleep at night so
that's when i picked up drugs
i needed to to numb
you know to suppress
going out here and with these sick
individuals
i rounded up on skate road in my first
drug program
and i got kicked out of there and that's
when i winded up on ski roads
smoking dope um deeply uh
selling myself and uh
jacking people all that [ __ ] came along
with skid row
shaking [ __ ] pockets up and
down
um
having unprotected sex what [ __ ]
said
you could really look at them and like
possibly tell that they had something
and
in fact i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and
open up and share this
and i'm still i'm still waiting um for
the results to come back i just uh
right when my husband died i turned my i
turned my first trick again
and uh it was with somebody that had
full blown
aids and i knew they had full boiled
aids
but uh i had the [ __ ] my husband was
gone
and uh i can't commit suicide it's not
an option
i knew this person had full blown aids
but i want to weigh out so bad that
i mean this life to me ain't worth
really living no more
i mean my husband was my everything and
uh
without him i feel
i just feel like
all these [ __ ] out here that
just uh my husband was a good
solid man and all these nothing ass
[ __ ]
i mean it's many nights that i lay out
here now
that i am on the street again due to my
husband's death
i'm back smoking again harder than i
ever before in fact
i tried to suck my first dick two weeks
ago without a condom
i mean they say the runs get it gets
progressively worse and all that [ __ ]
all the dues and the gets and [ __ ] i
knew this person had full blown aids
but to make that hundred dollars i went
ahead and did it
and every other day i'm going to get
tested
i got my two dogs now which is shadow
and teddy
and then the only thing that keeps me
going right now that keeps
me from snapping um i look at all the
foul [ __ ] that people do out here
and i feel like they don't deserve to
live here it is my husband
a good honest man from the most vicious
notorious gang that there is
latin kings they call him blocky rest in
peace
here it is this man changed
for the better not for the worse and
here it is his life was taken
he should still be in
and without him
i feel i feel nothing
um
where are you living now right now i'm
living on skid row
you're an attempt uh no i don't i don't
do the tense anything i do i want you to
see me doing it i try to do it in a
respectable way
but there there ain't no closed doors
out here
[ __ ] a tent anybody could plant a bug in
your tent
and how are you supporting yourself um
i'm backless prostitute
um yeah i mean it's hardball again i'm
smoking dope
i'm prostituting again on the low cause
i got the dogs
if i find a dog sitter and uh
i got a two bedroom voucher but because
the kovic is really hard to find a place
so at this point i don't know where my
life
is gonna what turn it's gonna make will
i make it out of here
i mean i don't know
do i want to make it out of here yeah
but then no
speaking yes and no
you know and that's because i don't got
my husband
that was my everything but the way i see
him now
spirit on a spiritual tip god has broken
me down
for that i could find so that i could be
real rebuilt again
and what i gather then i'm gonna end it
at this
he wants me to want nobody but him
he's a jealous god he wants me to depend
on
nobody but him he wants me to need
nobody but him hell he knows what i'm
gonna get my neck said
you know he knows where it's coming from
who's going to give it to me
so
that's just basically that's just about
it
and this is where i am today right here
in the heart of skid row
once again
you